they're like man these guys just expect
me to sell all day
and the answer is yes
i wanted to make this because i woke up
with this on my mind and i think it was
relevant so i was looking through our um
our weekly reports and uh i was looking
at the sales team stuff and i was
looking at uh the glx stuff which is our
fulfillment side
and uh i thought this was really
fascinating i would share this with you
so
one of the things that happens is we get
a lot of people uh who come on and they
say you know we're
like hey what's your goal right now what
are you trying to accomplish right and
a lot of gyms are like man if i could
get 300 members that would be amazing if
i get 200 members that'd be amazing i'd
get 500 members that would be amazing
right
and so they have these goals right and
yet
they don't follow the simple math of
getting there and so most
times the inflow is the cap right
now there's obviously like you've
probably heard if you've if you've ever
followed my stuff for long enough you'd
know that i talk a lot about retention
about lifetime value etc
right but at a basic level there
there is at some point what i would
consider acceptable metrics right
and what that means is let's say that
you're uh you know if you're in the
service based business you're never
going to get your churn below one
percent
to i mean it's just it's very unlikely
right and that's and if you are in that
it's typically because you're growing
purely off organic referrals which is
awesome but
if you want to be massive you need to
grow off everything you need to grow off
organic you need to grow off outbound
you need to grow off
paid acquisition right running ads and
the issue that i just continue to see is
and so then so
this last week i think we had like 10
gyms um
pause on glx and so glx is our kind of
done for you side
and all 10 of them paused because there
was too much inflow
they could not handle the lead flow and
the appointments
uh that were being set for them and i'm
gonna pause that right right there
and layla was on a podcast this last
week as well
with uh i think it was push press i
think it's push press and uh the ceo
push press was like you know
um we've we've heard that
the number one complaint that that we
hear from people you know from our
customers who have worked with you is
that
they're like man these guys just expect
me to sell all day
and the answer is yes because that's
what you said you wanted
right and so what's interesting for me
is most people want a full gym until
they actually have a full gym or see
what's required to get a full gym
right and so when we used to fly out and
force gyms to grow because we
didn't have limiting beliefs around
growing a gym someone would have 80
clients at their crossfit
and then in 21 days they'd have 280
clients at their crossfit
and they'd be like holy [ __ ] what do i
do
i did not sign up for this it's like
actually you did sign up for this
and so it reminds me oh i'm gonna pull
this up for you my favorite
my favorite magic cards of all time all
right was called burning wish
so dr cashy sent me a card versus really
cute of him and uh
underneath it says she wished for a
weapon but for not the skill
sorry she wished for a weapon but not
for the skill to wield it
and i feel like a lot of times that's
what happens is uh at least for the the
people who are coming in
to glx underprepared is they're like
i really want to grow i want to get new
customers right our top client right now
in the last 30 days sign up 100 new
130 new clients all right 130
and we actually that's in the last 30
days but she signed up
130 in the last two and a half weeks
so if we give it another like one and a
half weeks she'll probably
top 200 new clients all right
if you want a 200 300 400
500 person facility and you are not able
to sign up
20 new clients a week you will not get
there
right because this is where the
acceptable metrics parts comes in
i would like to give you permission that
if you have a service based business
all right services of any kind anything
that is easy
in is easy out and you're like well i
mean we have to onboard them and block
which you should be right
but easy in service is easy in switching
from
your crm to another crm not easy
right big pain in the ass and so the
likely that you switch is very very low
which is why software and things like
that are much stickier
than services are and so you have to
kind of accept that that comes with the
territory
so if you're selling service and you
want to be big
then you have to know that there's going
to be a back end churn that's going to
occur
and that's just because easy and easy
out that's how it works right
but if you have easy in and you're not
maximizing the fact that that's your
advantage and services that you can
scale quickly
right your inflow then
you're not using one of the primary
advantages of being a service provider
right and so if it's like i want to get
to to 200 or let's say let's say let's
say 300 members right i want to get to
300 members okay cool you want to get to
300 members
now your turn is 10 industry average
and you can only sign up
10 trials a week and that's you maxed
out right 10 new
prospects per week that give you a
credit card for some front-end program
or a trial of some sort
right you can only sign up 10 of those a
week now even somebody who comes in and
signs up straight into eft what we have
noticed is we still have to resell them
on a longer term because really there's
the i'm going to try it
phase and then there's the i'm going to
commit phase and even if like i said you
sign someone up for recurring it doesn't
actually mean they'll stick until they
really make the second sale and we've
seen that across the board for us and
our gyms at least okay
so if you can only take on 10 new
new potential prospects right per week
and that's your cap
and you want to get to 300 members then
that would mean that you have to convert
75 of them week in week out and a lot of
people are not doing that
and 10 mind you means that you're
closing
uh 50 of four calls a day right that are
showing and let's say you're getting
half those calls which means you have to
have eight scheduled appointments a day
now most gyms that i talk to
don't even have they're they're stressed
out of their mind with that
right but that's just for them to get 20
or 30 new customers a month
you want to get to 500 you want to get
to 400 you have to accept the fact that
you're gonna be selling all day
because you're selling a service and
you're trying to get to a high number
and so
most times most times people have goals
and are disconnected from the actions
that are required to get there
right the numbers the basic math and
most people just don't do the math
like so i would highly encourage you if
you know what your turn is
look backwards and think okay if i'm
going to lose
20 customers a month and i'm at 200 and
i want to get to 400
a lot of times you don't just double
your inflow like sometimes you have to
do even more than that because you also
lose some efficiency on the back it's
part of the game right
and so if you're at 10 you're losing 20
all right and so if you know you're
converting half of your trials that
means you have to make 40 sales a month
all right the industry average by the
way is 35 which would mean that if you
wanted to replace those 20 you'd have to
sell 60 trials a month
okay of some sort 60 front-end programs
of some sort
per month if you can't do that
you will never grow and you will always
wonder why
all right and so this message is
basically for anyone who wants
to be a big dog if you want to dominate
the market which is the marketing that
most people respond to
like dominate your competition blah blah
all that kind of stuff right
you want to be a seven-figure gym okay
cool then you have to do the math that
seven-figure gyms do
and i do not know a single one of them
that do not know how
to take on high numbers of traffic on a
weekend
week out basis right what i continue to
see is
i'm gonna turn my ads on for a couple
weeks and i'll turn them off and then we
gotta go service those people no no
no no if you want to scale your inflow
never stops
you have to be able to sign up people
this week and next week and the week
after that and the week after that
and fulfill you need to be doing both
things concurrently
and if you're incapable of doing that it
means you're not able to manage your
schedule
of your team right they have to know
that the first
two hours of the day it's blocked on
their time is going for outbound
uh for for ongoing fulfillment like
they're reaching out to your existing
customers to make sure that they stay
then you have two hours a day that's
blocked for onboarding for new customers
then you have
orientations right all that stuff and
then you have sales and you have to
disperse the meetings that have to
happen in order to make this entire
model work
right and that's with any service
business like this works the same for us
right we've got sales appointments
we have kickoff calls we have builds
that happen in the background
and then we have ongoing check-ins to
make sure the clients are doing well
right beyond that we still have daily
calls with me to make sure that they're
being able to sell and convert and all
that kind of stuff right and so
the whole point of this is if you're not
where you want to be
a lot of time it's because your inflow
is your bottleneck and you haven't
operationally prepared yourself
for what it actually looks like to sign
up a hundred people in a month
right 50 60 80 new people in a month the
math is there
if you want to do it you can do it but
i'm just seeing this
like more times than not and then and
like when
when dan said it from push press that
the no more complaint that people got
from jim watch is like they're just
they just flood you know they flooded me
with lee they expected me to sell a date
yeah because that's what you said you
wanted so either switch your goal or
switch your head right like because like
if you want to get to here
it's just math backwards right and so
just most people have not done that math
so here's how you do the math if you
want to grow
to let's say uh 300 members
okay and let's say your churn is 10
that means you need to sign up 30 people
per month to break even
now let's just get those 30 done let's
say you convert half because to get the
300 you have some skills right
so you're converting half your front end
people which means you're at 60 new
signups per month that's 15 a week
all right now if you're selling one out
of two that you're that you're talking
to
now you're talking 120 a month uh of
people
who you're talking to ever so that's 30
a week
roughly right that you're talking to and
you're probably selling only five days
or
now here's another one i could go off
one is like we only sold two days a week
it's like well good luck trying to sell
100 you know 30 people in two days it's
not it's very unlikely that it's going
to happen
right so if you're not let's say you're
selling six days and you're selling 30.
so you gotta sell five people a day i'm
sorry meet with five people per day
which is not that unreasonable
it's five thirty minute sessions it's
two and a half hours three hours of
sales a day like this is not crazy
right um now you're still going to have
show ups right which is going to be
another inefficiency all right so to go
30 goes to 60 appointments a week
oh interesting all right now we're at 60
appointments a week
and we're just maintaining 300 we're not
even growing to get there yet
interesting right and so now we're
seeing how this math starts to work out
you're like okay
so now if i wanted to grow an extra 30
on top of that
then i need to have even more i've
needed double what i just said
okay and so we have 30 conversions
from 60 front in sales which is half of
120 meetups
120 uh client conversations per month
okay that and then you have half of
those that show for their appointments
and then you need to double that to grow
right that's the math and so if you're
not
able to deal with that math then you
will not get there
and sometimes it's just like just giving
the the sheer reality of the situation
is like
it's a volume game it's a math game it's
the same people who get
bent out of shape over one person who
says i gotta talk to my husband i don't
have my card on me it's like cool
move on champions have short memories
right they bounce back fast they're
unaffected by losses because they're
just thinking
i know i need to close half which means
here's the news flash
if you have to meet with 200 people a
hundred people are gonna say no
and you have to be emotionally okay with
that because you just understand
the numbers right you be like i don't
know i mean you should try and get
better at your craft
always of course right but
if you just can't accept emotionally and
this is what i continue to see
is that some guys just can't take the
emotional beating of having people say
no
which is why they'll never grow right
and like the most experienced
sales people they don't get bothered
they're like yeah they understand that
people come with their own preconceived
notions to the call
it's not about you the salesman it's
about them right
and just remembering it's about them so
don't get butt hurt if for some reason
someone says no
of course they have excuses that's why
they're not in shape of course they have
limiting beliefs that's why they're not
in shape
and so if we're going to expect that
they're not going to come with emotional
baggage to the call or to the meeting
it's ridiculous right and so then if
we're to take this back
one step right and we said let's say 240
uh
consoles we we're gonna have to be
generating 15 leads a day
right roughly huh well what does it take
to get 15 leads a day
in cost well right let's back into it
15 leads a day 10 bucks a lead or 150 a
day it's 4 500
in ad spend per month just the math
and i think that a lot of people don't
confront them at they make these goals
and don't think about what it takes to
get there and then as soon as it even
gets to a third
of what it would actually take to get
there to achieve what they want
they're like oh my god this is just so
much so well yeah
if that's what you want then this is how
this is how it works
it's like well i want to be a champion
bodybuilder okay well i can only work
out three days a week for an hour
okay good luck okay
right and so it's like do you want to be
a champion or do you just want to be
another person who also ran and that's
fine if that's what you want it's just
i'm not hearing that that's what you
want
so either people need to get real clear
on what they really want
or re and and and then make the
adjustments accordingly
or realize that it's not actually their
priority
and that could go into a whole other
thing about like priorities are just
priorities there's never really
conflicting priorities you just have one
that is a bigger priority than another
and if it conflicts then the other one
is a secondary priority
and sometimes priorities do conflict in
terms of their nature but not their
importance
and so you just need to figure out which
of these things is more important to me
right and most times it's simply being
able to delegate time
and appropriate on a calendar when
things need to get done
if we know that we have to onboard 30
new customers per week
then how do we fit let's say 30
30 minute consultations in okay that's
15 hours a week i've got one team member
they're here five days a week there's
three hours on their on their calendar
great so now that one person has three
hours a day on their calendar
five days a week for taking on new
customers okay that seems reasonable
they still have another five hours
right and if they have to do conversion
meetings which is to convert them into a
long-term membership
from a trial or a front-end program now
uh
from from those people we know that we
again have 30 people we got to meet with
and so of those 30 people and it's to
say it's going to take a 30 it's a 30
minute console to sell someone into
membership
boom now that person's at six hours a
day all right this is just one employee
and so this one employee is now managing
the onboarding and the conversion sales
right and then they have two hours a day
to do continuous reach outs to the
existing customers
great that is a role right and then you
have a sales person who's gonna
what i mean that has to be a full-time
sales person who's gonna hit those
numbers right
they're gonna meet with 60 people right
60 people six days a week it's 10 a day
right 30 minutes it's only five hours
right and so if you're looking at this
this is the game is how long does it
take
how many of them do we have block the
time and that is how you scale
that's it that's all there is right and
just and just
confronting the math now you can try and
tweak it in control but you have to
understand
you're not going to have orders of
magnitude improvements you're not going
to sell 100
of people who show up you're not going
to keep 100 of people a month over a
month
it just doesn't happen right it just it
just doesn't and so you have to you
deal with what is right you're always
going to try to improve and that's
normal
but if you wait for always your
improvements you will never start
and you will never get to where you're
trying to go and so that is my message
for the week
is that um your inflow is probably your
bottleneck and there has to be
acceptable metrics that you can
extrapolate off of
and then work backwards into how much
time that's required and how many people
are required to help you get there
and if that means for you as the
provider or the owner of the business
that you need to work double time in
order to afford the person who's going
to be able to
release the bottleneck then that is part
of the game all right
so anyways i hope you guys have an
amazing monday i hope you look at money
math and i hope you look at time math to
figure out how you can break your
bottlenecks
so you can get to the gym that you want
whether that's corona
or not corona or remote or launching
anything or
you have a b2b business it doesn't
matter the metrics are all the same
all right so lots of love hope you guys
are stoked uh for this week because i am
we're super excited and i will catch you
guys all soon all right
you